whilst what you might see is written on
the heading
seems pretty pedestrian there's not much
to it
in a sense that is correct but in
another sense welcome
in another sense actually there's um
some really cool and important stuff
in here that you should not
so what's the phrase i'm looking for um
you you treat this as simple and routine
at your own risk there's actually a
really important concept underneath here
which we'll dive into
shortly so why don't we like the best
way to understand what this is all about
is just by having a look at an example
question
you know by now that if you have been
given
some derivative function f dash x equals
this
then we know you got that derivative
function by
differentiating so if we wanted to
return to our
original function by the way not the
derivative what's it called when we've
gone back
the primitive because like from back in
those days you want to find the
primitive
then of course the method that we use is
integration
no big deal right but the question um as
stated
we know that what we would get out of it
out of that process of integration is
not just any integral what kind of
integral would we get
out of this question an indefinite
integral thank you very much because
at the moment you integrate uh in fact
let's go ahead and do
exactly that if we were to want to get f
of x
the way we would do it is by saying well
let's integrate
f dash right because
i have no boundaries here right there's
nothing not finding an area or something
like that you've been in trapezoidal
rule recently
there's no boundaries so this is
definitely indefinite
definitely indefinite this is certainly
indefinite which means
we're going to get this constant
integration flying at the end why don't
we go ahead and do that
this is not a complicated thing to
integrate i've got 4x
minus 1 with respect to x
so go ahead help me out what do i get
2 x squared because i raised that
index i divided by that index 4 goes
into 2 and then
wonderful okay so there's my indefinite
integral
no problems but sometimes we are given
enough information
or we want to actually not just say it's
some family of functions um we call this
the the linearity of integration
and this could be 2x squared minus x
plus 1
plus 100 plus whatever you want minus
whatever you want
and they're all kind of on a line
linearity we can actually if we're
provided more information which i'm
about to give you
we can be a little more specific we can
evaluate
this constant that we have here now the
particular example value or rather the
example
information that i was going to provide
you was
suppose we have some additional
function value for the primitive some
known
place that the primitive passes through
okay now
a common thing that you will get given
is f of 0 if you substitute
in x equals 0 you'll get some number
right because
x equals 0 or t for time equals 0 or
p for population equals 0 because that's
such a common thing to receive and
because 0 is 0
you often get called uh this often gets
called the initial condition
okay because oh at the start of this
where do we begin
but it doesn't have to be initial and
i'm going to give you a different one in
fact i'm going to say
f of 1 equals 3.
so i'm told the derivative and i'm also
told this one specific spot
that the function goes through now i
can't be
plus 1 plus 100 whatever i have to be
somewhere specific right and we're going
to find where that specific
spot is so if you're following along
step one was we did the indefinite
integral
but now i can go further because if this
is truly f of x
i can say but but and please like
emphasize what's going on here help me
follow
communicate to me clearly your your flow
of logic but i know that f of one now
that i've provided to you
is not just equal to anything it's equal
to three right so therefore this line
here i can actually just go straight
into
this line up here according to what i
have integrated i can say therefore
f of 1 would be don't skip anything here
2 of 1 squared help me out finish it off
minus 1 because i'm substituting in
x equals 1 yes plus c still don't know
what that is
what's that equal to three that's what i
have on my right hand side
so far so good and at this point this is
fairly routine
i want to know what c the constant
integration is i just have to do a bit
of tidying up looks to me like i've got
two take away 1 plus c equals 3.
that's a 1 on the left-hand side a plus
1. so what am i going to do to both
sides
i'm just going to minus 1 from both
sides which leaves me with this
we have successfully evaluated the
constant of integration but of course
as usual when you get to the end of like
oh i simplified some stuff
am i done yet am i done yet just one
last line what do i what does the
question actually ask
yeah i actually want the primitive and
this is just part of it so all i need to
do is just tie this up in a neat bow
i will say therefore f of x equals and
i'm going to substitute
c where it belongs two x squared minus x
plus two full stop happy
any questions before i go on
okay wonderful so let's just make sure
we knew what was going on there there's
basically three
turns that we take right what would you
call this
this is the actual integrate right after
you've done this
sort of calculus just steps out of the
way right so this is the integrate step
what did we do i would call it i guess
here
what would you call that yeah find the
constant or maybe because this is
what we're doing finding the value of
something got a word for that
i'm gonna call that evaluate okay and
then just i mean it hardly warrants
being called a step
but you do like this is a distinct thing
um i guess i would call that like you're
substituting right
you're taking that thing which you found
the value of c and you pop it where it
belongs
happy times okay now what i'm going to
say is
99 of you for 99 of questions will do
exactly this
might not be a polynomial that you have
it might be
you've learned how to do right what
kinds of functions can you do aside from
polynomials
exponentials what else trigonometric
functions what else
uh well we don't we won't differentiate
the logs themselves but we can land on
we can result in a log
if you have something like i don't know
three on three x minus one
that'll turn into a log won't it by the
way what was the thing a lot of you are
nodding
what was the pattern that you could see
here that told you this was going into a
log
what do you see very good it's not just
any fraction we call them rational
functions
not just any fraction becomes a log it's
of that particular form
whereby it's f dash on f and you're like
oh sweet
i've got reference sheet this reminds me
okay so we can integrate all these
things you're going to
see examples of those in the assigned
questions